hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Korra bonus video I wanted to do
a breakdown of all the sub bending
styles book 3 is all about introducing
the new airbending technique via Jinora
so I'll explain that too they weren't
super explicit when they mentioned it on
the show but Jinora had a few lines that
summed it up hello any new people if
you're finding me for the first time I
do weekly Korra videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm even doing a special Comic Con
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
this video so up to book 3 we've seen a
sub style for all the major bending
forums I remember whenever book 2 was
getting ready to be released last year
they talked about creating a new sub
style for air but whenever book 2 came
out and went by with no explanation
everyone was a little WTF confused
especially with that whole Jinora deus
ex machina raava save at the end
technically that was the sub style the
way they showed it in book 3 looked a
little bit different but it's projecting
your spirit jinora's words when she was
explaining to Kai were it's a high-level
Airbender move with some spiritual stuff
thrown in that actually made me chuckle
just a little bit because during the
book 2 DVD commentaries Mike and Bryan
talked about that finale where Jinora
pulled raava out of unavaatu they
explained that they didn't know what she
was doing specifically they just wanted
to see her resuscitate a little piece of
raava that was inside una vaatu but for
all intents and purposes just think of
the airbending sub style as spirit
bending not to be confused with energy
bending I guess in a way you could kind
of consider energy bending a sub style
of all forms of bending even though it's
strictly classified as its separate form
Jinora by far has the deepest connection
to the spirit world
aside from Korra on the show so of
course she'd be the one to demo the new
ability I love how the series just kind
of brushed over the fact that she
discovered it without any help since we
don't see a lot of Jinora scenes I'm
guessing she did sit down at some point
and work it out but Mike and Bryan just
decided not to show us the montage of
her figuring it out the other really
important thing about this sub style is
that it's very passive you know being
that airbending is kind of a passive
form of bending so would its sub style
but here's a breakdown of all the other
bending forms and their sub styles so
next on the cool list is combustion
there's actually three forms of
firebending including lightning
generation and lightning redirection but
sparky-sparky boom girl is killing it
right now so let's start with that
so combustion is just channeling your
Chi through a focus point
it's like a blast denoted by the third
eye tattoo all combustion vendors have
like sparky-sparky boom man and last
airbender and out by Leon Cora I say all
combustion benders but we've only seen
two and they both have the tattoo so
it's a bit of a stretch it's more of a
focus T PLAs than a searing burn you'd
get from regular firebending yes it is
true that Azula and other prodigy
firebenders can bend blue flame which is
way hotter but in terms of blast damage
combustion is way more effective it's
not like a machine gun though because
you're harnessing your Chi you have to
focus your energy so it takes time to
recharge if you lose focus like when
someone say throws a boomerang at your
face
the blowback can kill you like the
kickback from a giant gun squishing your
brains
so just because combustion man and last
airbender and PI Lee encore right now
are the only known combustion vendors
it's not a genetic thing it's all about
spiritual alignment just like the other
forms of bending lightning generation
and redirection are much more common sub
styles of fire bending creating
lightning requires you to separate the
positive and negative energies in your
body like yin and yang in a physical
sense when you're able to control the
interaction of positive and negative
energy the bender guides it outward
towards the fingertips resulting in a
charge leaving the body in the form of
electricity they call it lightning just
because it's discharged the charge of
the blast can be regulated like using a
dimmer switch on a light bulb Iroh
claims that he thought of lightning
redirection after watching water benders
but he's just the first person to talk
about doing it that doesn't necessarily
mean he was the one that came up with it
it's a little bit more like using your
body as a conduit so one of the coolest
things whenever I first started watching
Korra was watching them in Republic City
using lightning bending to generate
electricity for the city just in a
completely casual way it was so funny it
totally makes sense that as bending
becomes more sophisticated it starts
being used as a commodity so moving on
to the next coolest waterbending so the
substyles
our blood bending and healing during
last airbender hummock lames that she's
the first one to figure out blood
bending just realizing that most people
are made of water but I always wonder if
she and Iroh for instance are just the
first people to be recorded talking
about special bending techniques so
jumping forward to Korra the reason why
you kown tarrlok and Amon were able to
blood Ben during the day or you know at
any time was because one they were very
proficient benders and two just because
they practice
a lot when your blood bending it looks
like you're making a person move against
their will but really what you're doing
is manipulating the liquid in their
bodies every organic process in your
body requires water molecules h2o they
coat the membranes that float in all
parts of your body most notably around
your bones and your muscles so by moving
those it makes it look like you're
moving your muscles the reason it's so
hard to do is because you're focusing on
those small molecules that coat the
muscles and on the flipside healing is
less powerful but it's way more
practical so it involves using the
healing based properties of water as
well as water bending in an energy based
context you can treat certain types of
wounds and because it's energy based you
can detect problems with the person's
chi woon Locke was also able to use this
to quote-unquote heal dark spirits I
know they didn't explain that in book 2
very much but he's using a slight
variation on Katara's healing ability to
calm the spirits and then taught it to
Cora part of the reason why I think the
Cora was not able to heal those spirit
vines away in Republic City is because
there wasn't anything wrong with them if
they had been dark spirit vines I think
that her technique would have worked but
they weren't attacking the buildings or
going crazy in an unnatural way they
were supposed to be there so moving down
the coolest we have earthbending sub
styles which are metal bending seismic
detection and lava bending I definitely
think that metal bending is one of my
favorite sub styles and I do think that
Bolin will eventually learn to metalbend
what you're doing is is bending the
trace unprocessed parts of the earth
elements in processed metals so the more
impure or unprocessed a metal is the
easier it is to bend your bending like
the little unprocessed bits of Earth in
metals just like a blood bender bent the
little bits of water surrounding your
muscles the reason Toph says she can't
bend platinum is because it's a pure
metal there are no bits of regular earth
left it will be like a blood bender
trying to bend sand in the desert even
though technically at night there is
moisture in the desert air the seismic
activity is a little bit different tough
actually learned that from the
badger-moles as a practical application
and just learning to get around on her
own you're basically using echolocation
so it does require you to feel
vibrations on your naked skin so that
they can travel through your body that's
why she always has to walk around
without shoes I always wondered how many
times she had to wash her feet during
the day
lava bending is something we saw
ghazan do whenever he was being broken
out of his prison this is a small
contradiction in the way they explained
it on Last Airbender but during that
series it was explained that only a
fully realized avatar could lava bend
because it involved concurrent use of
firebending and earthbending but since
we did see someone do it on Korra who is
not an avatar I'm assuming that he just
used the friction in the air to heat the
earth up like he just spun the earth so
fast that the air friction heated into
lava doing that Gazans
able to create superheated blades this
is a pretty small scale thing though
Avatar Roku was able to erupt a volcano
in avatar kyoshi was able to use it to
separate her island from the mainland so
moving on to the big mystery energy
bending it predates all the other forms
of bending and there currently aren't
any sub forms associated with it but
that doesn't mean that somebody in the
future won't think of one it's basically
when someone bends the life energy
inside another person right now we know
energy bending can be used to take away
or restore a person's bending and impart
knowledge instantly like beam
information into someone else's brain
it's been suggested that when the lion
turtles were giving bending to other
peoples during avatar wants time they
were doing so using energy bending so I
guess if Korra ever did develop her
energy bending skills enough she could
bestow bending on a non bender it
remains the biggest question mark of all
the bending styles so hopefully book 3
explores it a little bit more so moving
on to book 3 stuff they've released
titles for all the rest of the episodes
of the season there's going to be 13
total here they are in order
episode 6 and 7 tonight are called old
wounds in original benders respectively
episodes 8 and 9 next week are called
the taro thin in the stakeout then
episodes 10 and 11 the week after that
are called long live the Queen and the
ultimatum and then the two-part finale
episodes 12 and 13 are called Enter the
Void and venom of the Red Lotus some in
a way to speculate on what those episode
titles mean until my episode review
tonight be sure to subscribe to get that
I'll post it after the episodes they're
like around 10 p.m. Pacific time here's
the deal with my Comic Con giveaway next
week I'm doing my regular weekly Korra
giveaway just like normal but in
addition next week I'm also going to be
giving away a Pabu plush doll naga doll
or an oppo doll
winner basically gets to choose so I
will actually be at Comic Con and I'll
record The Legend of Korra panel
I'll upload that that's going to be on
July 25th that's basically next Friday
so I should be able to upload that by
that night
they're also airing two episodes next
week so I'll post a review for those two
in the meantime click here to get my
review of tonight's episodes episode 6 &
7 I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and click here to get my review
of episodes 4 & 5 thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives